well the same to Georgia last week two
people got into an argument at a
supermarket in a sane society that would
be the end no one would have heard about
it and those involved would have moved
on with their lives this is no longer a
sane society however so when a fellow
shopper told Georgia lawmaker Erika
Thomas she had too many items to use the
Express Checkout Lane she immediately
accused him of being evil and attacked
him on the basis of his race watch
people are getting really out of control
with this with this white privilege his
white man comes up to me and says you
lazy son of a [ __ ] that he is real and
for that white man to come up to me and
called me instead of a bitchin lazy and
go back where I came from because he had
a couple items he wanted to get in front
of me and he said I had 20 items in a
ten item lie well we'll make you that
angry - yeah that's somebody like that
but y'all see ill on Omar y'all see all
this stuff about sinner back in stuff
like it but it's getting out of control
there's so much hate in this world and
it's being incited by our president
every single day uh-huh so the press
having forgotten the last two or three
or was at four dozen fake hate crimes
immediately believed Thomas completely
and blamed the administration for clayey
creating a climate of hate they would
still believe her now if the man she
accused didn't come forward on his own
but he did come for his name is Erick
Sparks he's not a member of the Klan it
turns out he is Cuban and he's a
Democrat he's an avid Democrat a Liberal
Democrat and he says that Thomas lied
completely about what happened Thomas
didn't even fight back an interview with
local television station she had
backtracked and she said that actually
Sparks never said go back where you came
from huh
but it didn't matter to the New York
Times good journalists are supposed to
state the key facts first New York Times
does the opposite their headline said
this quote go back where you came from
George Georgia lawmakers says she was
told actually she said she was not told
that in the story The Times we did 14
paragraph support
telling you the reader that Thomas had
actually retracted her phony accusation
which seems like fraud probably suave is
associated a treason magazine and the
author of panic attack young radicals in
the age of Trump and he joins us Saint
Robbie you've done journalism your whole
adult life if you run a story with the
headline that is completely false and
you know it's false and in fact at graph
14 you concede it's false that's not
really journalism is it that's something
else no it's not it's not much of a
story it sort of starts to make you
wonder why was this even written who
decided a trivial dispute between two
stressed out shoppers is a national news
item and not only a national news item
but one that that confirms all these
sort of worse biases of the New York
Times readers about what's going on in
trumps America etc etc everything every
story must be about Trump right somehow
it's about racism and Trump when we get
to it with that angle has to be in there
we just have to find it that's the
operating thinking of so many people in
the mainstream media when this was just
this was not news this was something
that happened that just happens to
people and you know I think the guy was
kind of a jerk I think she was kind of a
jerk people are jerks to each other
that's it there's no story here so maybe
this the real point of the story had
nothing to do with Erika Thomas or
sparks the apparently falsely accused
perpetrator but it's really about the
people writing the story and the message
they're sending is we're good people
we're not like the president
we're virtuous I mean it does seem like
stories think that's a really a kind of
narcissism that are designed to make the
person telling the story seem like a
really good person yes they want their
good and they want you to be angry they
want you to be confused and angry and
think that everyone is out to get you
because that's what sells more
newspapers or attracts more people to
click on the article if there's you know
people are there's something you should
be mad about and everyone's mad about it
and why aren't you worked up enough yet
is the kind of ethos that prevails in
this
social media culture where you see
something looks bad you've decided
there's no need to follow up and you
know these stories are always more
complicated even even when they're true
there's always something more
complicated about them and we're we're
too quickly we're not looking into that
because no we know what we think already
and it must be that this is about Trump
of course you think the New York Times
would be above that but in fact they're
beneath it probably deep
thank you for that appreciate it thank
you